New York continues to come down the
curve officials are preparing for what's
next Governor Andrew Cuomo asking the
president to keep the Javits Center
makeshift hospital open and on standby
because he fears a possible second wave
of the corona virus come this fall I
spoke to the president about leaving
them in place until we get through the
flu season god forbid we need extra
capacity again the virus still holding a
tight grip on New York even as it comes
down the curve a second wave of antibody
testing revealing nearly 15% of
residents tested positive for kovat 19
antibodies Governor Cuomo saying he will
extend New York's paws order in many
parts of the state but while some are
ready to get back to business we have to
take rest because we need to
you know my family eating others have
mixed feelings I know everyone in New
York is so anxious to go back but we
have to take things slow as a right now
just coming out for essentials this
while the virus continues to take an
extreme toll on healthcare workers on
the front lines the head of the
emergency department at New York
Presbyterian Allen Hospital dr. Lorna
Breen taking her own life her father
saying she tried to do her job and it
killed her dr. Breen had contracted the
virus while on the job
she returned to work after nearly two
weeks of recovering her father telling
the New York Times make sure she has
praised a hero because she was reporting
in New York
Trinity Chavez Artie